hey everyone I'm Abbi short welcome to
Abby's kitchen ever since we started
solids with baby II I've been sharing
our meals and our baby led weaning
experience up on my Instagram stories
and you guys are loving it so I want to
give you more of that here on my channel
and so I also actually did a video
featuring our best friend daya Debbie or
we talked a little bit about some of the
benefits and concerns and myths when it
comes to baby like me so if you haven't
seen that definitely check it out right
here but if you're just getting started
baby like weaning essentially means
allowing baby to sell feed himself table
foods or finger foods without spoons
feeding him typical purees so if you're
ready to try baby led weaning with you
or baby but you just don't want to start
this is going to be your how-to guide
it's gonna be an amazing jumping-off
point for you and I'm gonna have so much
more great baby led weaning content in
the weeks to come so if you're not
already be sure to subscribe and you can
come back for some more great content ok
moms and dads let's do this so here's
some things we should be looking for so
babe should have some good neck control
and be able to sit up so that they could
spit out food without choking on it if
God forbid that were to happen they also
should be interested in food and showing
that interest by grabbing out food or
looking at food while you're eating it
opening their mouths to kind of try to
put food in those are all really great
signs and finally they should have lost
their tongue thrust reflex so basically
they don't just kind of push food out
the second that you put something in
their mouth so now we know that baby is
ready for food and baby led weaning
let's talk about how to offer foods and
what foods to offer
so the beauty of baby LEDs meeting is
that we can actually offer babes like
table foods and finger foods that the
family is already enjoying the only
ingredient that you really want to watch
out or is honey which of course is a
risk and should not be giving it to
babies until they're at least one years
old out of fear of botulism as well as
added sugars and salt but pretty much
everything else is fair game
as long as there's some modification for
texture and size to make it a little bit
easier for baby to eat well you can
definitely progress over time to harder
firmer foods as baby homes their feeding
skills when you first get started you
want to offer fruits and vegetables that
are soft enough that you could kind of
mash them with your fingers or baby
could mash them with their gums or
tongue that way even if they don't have
teeth yet they could still mash up the
food enough that they could safely
swallow so some foods you would
definitely have to cook them like bake
them or steam them really well in order
to get them soft enough for baby
eat so things like baby carrots or sweet
potato would be a really great example
other foods are naturally really soft so
that you can just offer them as is like
avocado or bananas another great one so
when you're just getting started you
definitely want to avoid really hard raw
fruits and vegetables that could break
off into a chunk large enough that could
cause baby to choke so things like raw
carrots or raw Apple are not great
choices when you're just getting started
with baby lightly now when it comes to
shape most babies don't develop a pincer
grasp until about 9 to 10 months which
basically just means that they don't yet
know how to pick up foods with their
thumb and their finger so we want to
make it as easy as possible for baby to
kind of get food into their mouth I
don't know my son what specially was
just getting started basically would
just take his whole hand and kind of
just like smear it into his mouth so one
of the things I like to do is to cook
things into kind of long finger like
shapes whenever possible so baby carrots
are already like that they're great
broccoli I like to cook with a bit of a
stock at the end so it's an easy thing
for him to kind of hold up like a handle
and things like melon or other fruit you
can cut into strips on the other end of
the spectrum a lot of babies struggle
with really soft kind of slit
foods like avocado cuz they could just
kind of slip right out of their hand and
then of course you just lost that food
to the dog in my case usually so one of
the things I like to do is to roll those
really soft kind of sweat or juicier
foods like avocado or really really ripe
mango and some ground almonds or ground
flax or a baby cereal because not only
is that gonna help with the grip but it
also can add a lot of iron and healthy
fats and other nutrients it's also
important to note that some food shapes
are not safe for baby when you're just
getting started using baby led weaning
so things like really hard round foods
like little baby cherry tomatoes or
whole grapes can technically get lodged
in baby's throat and cause it to choke
so you can definitely still serve these
kinds of foods in fact the grapes and
tomatoes are babies literally they're
his favorite foods of all time but you
might just want to cut them in half or
in quarters depending on their size and
I get it I know every single time I say
the word choke you guys are thinking
this is terrifying I could kill my baby
I get it I was there and honestly every
single time baby eat gags little I hold
my breath but the reality is it is so
rewarding to see your kid being able to
eat all of these foods independently all
on his or her own not to mention choking
is far less common than we actually
think it is and this is a skill feeding
and feeding oneself is a skill that they
need to master and I'm really proud that
I feel like I've given my baby a really
great start at this all right so let's
move on to talking about grades so when
it comes to grains there are so many
great options and honestly my kid like
most kids is a Carbajal ik so this is
really fun for me but I love doing like
whole-wheat pasta or a bean based pasta
ideally in a shape that's a little
easier for baby e to grab so things like
rotini or fusilli or penne or rigatoni
all are fan favorites in this house
so for bread I typically like to cut
these into little strips so it's really
easy for baby e to pick up and sell feed
I also like to serve my bread as toast
with some kind of butter or nut butter
spread and the reason for this is that
fresh bread
to get kind of gummy in baby's mouth and
kind of gum up into a big bowl but
really dry bread without and kind of
spread or butter or anything kind of
yummy on it can be a choking hazard
because it is so dry so having some kind
of butter toast or nut butter toast is a
really nice balance
oatmeal or other porridge grains can
absolutely be served as we normally do
kind of like mush but using baby led
weaning principles what I recommend
doing is pre-loading a little bit on to
a spoon and then handing it over to baby
or letting them pick up the spoon from
the tray so that they can self feed
themselves rather than you spoon feeding
them yes I know it's so messy to let
them try to negotiate with a spoon but
so is everything else in Parenthood so
just get used to it
so other whole grains like quinoa or
buckwheat or wheat berries they're all
totally fair game you could just serve
them like grains as is however in my
experience they're so small it's very
difficult for kids to be able to pick
each of those things up and they'll
definitely get really frustrated not to
mention it'll be very very messy so
typically I like to kind of cook them
into pancakes or make them into little
fritters and I've got lots of recipes
for these kinds of things on my blog so
check that out in the description below
now let's move on to dairy just like
what we talked about with the oatmeal
you can absolutely preload a little bit
of full fat plain yogurt or ricotta
cheese onto a spoon and then let baby
feed him or herself also not
surprisingly he is my son baby eat is
obsessed with cheese
iczer cheese at least once a day because
he it's like such a treat for him so
typically what I like to do is cut it
into little baton like kind of small
finger so you can easily pick it up also
large shreds also work really well easy
for him to kind of grab little pieces
but I could probably stay away from
really hard cheeses like parmesan not to
mention it's a saltier cheese as well
and go for lower sodium options like
mozzarella I always have buffalo
mozzarella in my house because I love
caprese salad and it's definitely one of
his favorites too cuz it's naturally
lower in sodium and it's also super soft
so it's really easy to eat and it's
delish so why not so let's talk about
protein foods so I think that a lot of
parents find that getting those protein
who's into their kids is probably the
most challenging part when it comes to
feeding however it's arguably also the
most important iron is a really
important nutrient for new eaters
because by six months
breast milk no longer provides enough
iron for babies to meet their needs so
we want to make sure we're offering lots
of iron and protein rich foods like meat
poultry fish eggs and nuts all of which
are really great sources of iron to help
baby meet their needs when it comes to
meat moisture is key because really dry
meats and kind of get stuck in baby's
throat so I always look produce your
higher fat meats that can break down in
baby's mouth so things like meat balls
are gray or braised meats or fish and of
course you want to make sure that you're
carefully removing any little bones or
skin eggs you just want to make sure
that they're cooked through but you can
scramble them you can make it into an
omelet and cut it into strips or
frittata and cut it into strips so it's
really easy for baby to pick up and hold
and you can also feel free to add in any
of your favorite herbs spices and
veggies to expand baby's palate for
beans and legumes I love to preload a
little bit hummus onto meat or veggies
or toast and you can also add coke
legumes to your favorite pancake or
muffin or fritter recipe as for nuts I
would say avoid any cool raw nuts as
they could potentially be a choking
hazard but I think it's a great idea to
add a thin layer of peanut butter to
things like toast not too thick of
course because it can get stuck on the
roof of their mouth and also be a bit of
a choking hazard
but I also love adding nut butters to
any fritters or pancakes muffin batters
Oh meal literally anything that I'm
serving babyyyyy I try to sneak some nut
products in there at least every few
days and I'm definitely gonna do another
video on introducing allergens in the
near future but for now just know that
it is recommended that we introduce
these allergens early and a final note
on iron for your best absorption bang
for the buck you want to pair it with a
source of vitamin C so you'll see that I
always incorporate some kind of fruits
and vegetables into every iron rich meal
and then finally it let's talk fat well
not an official food group I do think
it's really important to talk about fat
because babies do not need a low-calorie
low-fat diet they need lots of healthy
fats in their diet to thrive and grow so
make sure that you're cooking with
generous amounts of
and incorporating lots of healthy fats
like avocado and nut butter so I hope
this little how-to gives you some
inspiration to get started with baby led
weaning if you like this video there's
gonna be so much more baby content
coming so be sure to subscribe to the
channel give this video the thumbs up
and leave me a comment below some of
your concerns or experiences around
starting solids hope to see you guys
soon
thanks so much bye